Let's suppose that computer A wants to send a
file to computer B. The file transfer program on
A asks the file system to read the file
from the disk. The communication system then sends the
file, and finally the communication system sends the packets.
On the receiving side, the communication system. Gives the
file to the file transfer program on B, and
that file transfer program asks to have the file
written to disk. So what can go wrong in
this simple file transfer setup? Well first, reading and
writing from the file system can result in errors.
There may be errors in breaking up and reassembling the
file. And finally there may be errors in the
communication system itself. Now, one possible solution is to ensure
that each step has some form of error checking,
such as, duplicate copies, redundancy, time out and retry, so
forth. One might even do packet error checking
at each hop of the network. One could send
every packet three times. One might acknowledge packet reception
at each hop along the network. But the problem
is that none of these solutions are complete.
They still require application level checking. Therefore it may
not be economical to perform redundant checks at different
layers and at different places of this particular operation.
Another possible solution is an end-to-end check and retry
where the application commits or retries based on the
check sum of the file. If errors along the
way are rare, this will most likely finish on the
first try. Now, this is not to say that
we shouldn't take steps to correct errors at any one
of these stages. Error correction at lower levels can
sometimes be an effective performance booster. And the trade off
here is based on performance, not correctness. So
whether or not one should implement additional correctness
checks at these layers depends on whether or
not the amount of effort put into the reliability
gains are worth the extra trouble. Another example where the intend
arguement applies is with encryption, where keys are maintained by the end
applications, and cypher text is generated Before the application sends
the message across the network. Now one of the
key questions in the end to end argument is
identifying the ends. The end to end argument says
that the complexity should be implemented at the ends
but not in the middle, but the ends may
vary depending on what the application is. So for
example, if the application or protocol involves Internet routing,
the ends may be routers, or they might be ISPs.
If the application or protocol is a transport
protocol, the ends might be end hosts. So, identifying
the ends in the end-to-end argument is always
a thorny question that you have to answer first.